and start the recording i'll give you a
countdown from
five um and then i'm gonna cut myself
off at one or two just to get a clean
cut and then you can get started
okay alrighty
starting in five four
three two
hello everybody my name is daniel suter
i'm a professor in the department of
biological sciences at purdue
university i would like to thank the
organizers for giving me the opportunity
to talk about some of our work
specifically
today about our project on the role
of reactive oxygen species in axonal
growth and guidance
alab overall is interested in
understanding the
basic cellular and molecular mechanisms
of nervous system
development and regeneration
and in this project specifically we look
at the role of nox derived
rs in a nervous system development
in two model systems in
aprilia californica and zebrafish this
title slide here shows
two images on the left side you see a
cross section
through the eye of a wild type zebrafish
embryo at two days of
development two stains in blue nuclear
stain
and in green a stain for retinal gallium
cells
rtc's you see the nice layering
of the retina and also you can see
the knife formation of the optic nerve
as the axons
come together from the next important
cells exiting
the eye on the right side it looks very
different
and this is a section through the eye
of a corresponding nox2 mutant
so this fish doesn't have any functional
energy pitch oxidase too
this enzyme produces superoxide so this
is
uh this eye is completely
different the layering is not happening
and also
the retinal ganglion cells don't form
axons together and
they don't exist the eye
in the same fashion so this provides
evidence that already
from this complex are really important
in
retinal ganglion cell development as
well as making connections to the brain
so this is the outline of my talk i will
focus
in the background briefly on axonal
growth and guidance
i will then cover our experiments that
we conducted with the octetia model
system about the role of nox-derived ros
regulation of cross-contacting dynamics
and uric growth
and in the last part i will focus on our
studies
that we conducted in the zebrafish model
system about
nox2 and how it regulates the
development of these retinal tactile
connections
i would like to give credit upfront to
the people that did
the work we started all this work of
video monamalai a former graduate
student lab that did these studies in
euplegia
which were then picked up by corey
weaver another
radisson in my lab and he will send
these experiments into the zebrafish
model system which were then followed
by hayley roder a former master student
and offline kerose a graduate student
that just
graduated from my lab recently
so what is actual growth and guidance
so like myself
when i need to find my way to work this
is indicated by this path here
on the aerial view of west lafayette the
neuron worldcon
has to find its way to the park itself
so i need to read queues to find my way
from point a
which is where i live to point b is
where i work
so that the growth con needs needs to
look for cues in the environment of the
embryo
these cues can be different it can be
molecular but also
physical cues now this work is relevant
in a number of aspects we would like to
have a better understanding of basic
normal nervous system development
indicated here
by this diagram showing human brain
development
but obviously also to better understand
developmental disorders such as l1
syndrome indicated here
or to develop better treatments for
regeneration following
injury and diseases such as alzheimer's
disease the neuronal growth cone is this
highly motile
structure at the tip of axons as
indicated here in the upper left
panel this is an image of a hippocampal
neuron
in culture this was recorded in the lab
of my colleague dr
peter hollenbeck and it shows the growth
at the end of the axon it's stained for
a vaccine in red
and microtubules in green then
on the right of that we see a schematic
of a typical growth con
with more details we see the different
domains
the peripheral domain or p domain the
transition zone
or t zone and then the sample domain or
c sum these different domains
have different distribution of the
cytoskeleton
the effect of cytoskeleton is
particularly in the
p domain in the form of fallopodia
indicated in the schematic and
lamborghini
the microtubules are predominantly in
the central domain
but they also penetrate into the
periphery as you can
see in the schematic and they interact
with the effect inside the skeleton
and these interactions and both
cytoskeletons are really important for
neural outgrowth growth connectivity
and growthcon guidance then
in the lower panel we see three images
on the left we see
a low power phase contrast image of a
cultured obligion neuron
and then we see in the middle a
differential interference contrast or
dic
image of a growth con and the different
domains
again like those with central domain
conditions on amp domain and we can see
the nice structure
of this growth cone and on the right
side correspondingly
we see the cytoskeletal staining of this
gross cone
shown in the middle so in red f-actin
and in green microtubules thing
so how do obligate look like if you have
never seen athleisure these are
invertebrates live in the ocean they're
really cool animals and they've been
used quite a bit
in nervous system studies uh
why because their nerve cells are very
large
and people have used them to do
electrophysiology
we're using them for imaging purposes
because these growth cons are so
large you have seen on the scale bar
that these growth guns can be as wide
as 100 micrometers
this also allows us to do very nice
quantitative studies both with respect
to dynamics but also mechanics
just an example of that is shown here
so this slide talks about measuring
microtubule dynamics using the technique
called fluorescent speckle microscopy
developed by claire walderman store and
ted solomon
and this technique is in principle very
simple
it uses the low labeling of filament
structures
by incorporation of only a small amount
of labeled subunits such as tubulin in
this case
and then you get a speckled appearance
of the microtubule as
indicated here in the lower panel this
is from our work
what you see here is a time-lapse
montage
where you see different
points of a single microtubule growing
and shrinking and also translocating
so the time is going from left to right
and the distance is showing along the
y-axis and
these time intervals were five seconds
here
we color-coded the growing microtubule
in green and the same magnitude when it
shrinks in magenta
you can see the little dots and an
internal
dot or speckle is providing a reference
point for translocation
the addition of new dots provide us
with the ability to quantify the rate of
assembly or shrinkage
so i would like now to move on to
our story about rf signaling in nervous
system development
so this diagram talks about
rs concentrations their sources and
their effects
so there are both exorcist sources on
the right
and endogenous sources and many are
listed here and both
ultimately affect the concentration of
rose
so on the right you will have high
concentrations on the left
concentrations and these are also
affected by
antioxidant defense systems indicated
here
so it's well known that at two high
concentrations of rs
you have impaired physiological function
you have obviously stress your aging
of diseases and damage to the cell
now more recently work from our lab and
others have shown that if you have too
low
rs as shown here on the left you also
are compared
physiological functions and some
examples of that
are decreased motility decreased
proliferation
effective host defense and effective
gravity perception so it appears now
that somewhere in the middle is the best
for cells so whereas homostasis
where you have normal growth and
metabolism and normal functioning
signaling pathways
now what about rest in the nervous
system obviously the brain
needs a lot of oxygen and therefore the
brain is particularly vulnerable
to obsolete stress secondly
it has been shown that nadph oxidase
derived rs have been
implicated in neurodegenerative diseases
such as alzheimer's and parkinson's and
als but also
following injuries such as spinal cord
injury
however there's also evidence that
ross derived from energy pitch
oxidatives play a role
in normal neuronal function such as
differentiation
synaptic function and plasticity and
gravity perception
the rework here is to ask the question
do rs play a role
in axonal growth and guidance
so moving on to the second part now to
our studies
on rs in growth community and actin
dynamics
in the application model system
again these were conducted by vidya and
corey weaver
so what are our hypothesis so with
respect to growth
we think the most simple hypothesis
would be that intermediate rs
concentrations are shown here in the
middle in the green
are best for optimal uric roles while
too high concentrations on the right and
two low concentrations on the left
will reduce neural growth with respect
to growth con guidance we can envision
multiple scenarios but some simple
hypotheses
are depicted here if you think about
a repulsive q indicated by the red
gradient on the right side the growth
con
would turn away from that source this
could be mediated by an increase of
rs as indicated here by the red color
on the left side on the other hand if
you have an attractive positive q
such a q could introduce a small
increase in rs levels that actually has
a positive effect
so depending on the level of cross cones
in the cytosol of the growth curve
you may get either positive or negative
effects and that kind of correlates with
the
curve on the left side the gross curve
this diagram talks about the
molecular pathway that we envisioned for
some of these responses
so it starts all with a guidance cue
for example click to binding its
receptor and starting an initial
signaling cascade
this signaling cascade initially then
activates
the nadph oxidase in this case knox 2.
nox2 is a multi-solid enzyme complex
that has two components in the plasma
membrane
in green here nox2 and in purple p22
but they are not sufficient in this case
because they are being activated by
cytosolic subunits labeled here as p67
p47 and p40 as well as
rack in its gtp bond form
26 sobbins come together then
the complex produce the superoxide on
the outside of the cell from
oxygen this quickly converts into
hydrogen peroxide
either on its own or by enzymatic
reactions
and then hydrogen peroxide can
interact and react with the cell surface
but also go back into the cell through
channels
inside the cell additive peroxide can
modify a number of proteins
possibly signaling molecules such as
sarc cytoskeletal proteins such as
actin which ultimately changes the
dynamics
and the organization of the act inside
the skull
so that's our hypothesis now let's look
at some data
in this part of the talk so this
here which i show you evidence that
reducing ros levels reduces effect
the top panel shows on the left again uh
roscommon schematic
you already have seen that and then two
images of a control rose
under normal condition efc in the middle
and
effecting the microtubule staying in red
and green respectively on the right side
on the lower panel this growth con has
been treated with an antioxidant
called pvn so this is not an inhibitor
so we have to use
millimolar concentrations to
significantly
reduce rs levels in these growth cones
and the effect of that is
in here very clearly in the middle panel
you see the growth gun becomes flatter
phytopodia extend and ultimately stall
and don't grow anymore
and also the central domain grows
forward
and the ruffles in the transition zones
disappear
when you look under the hood at the side
of this code then you can see that the
effect inside the skeleton is much
diminished you see that
in panel b double prime so there is less
attracting compared to control
and also microtubules extend towards the
periphery so major changes with the
cytoskeletal amounts rearrangements
and also the growth cone dynamics
when we then specifically inhibit nadph
oxidases
with an inhibitor in this case the
inhibitor is called
vas 2870 that's in the lower panel
we again reduce the effecting content so
the top panel shows
the vehicle control the miso the ic on
the left
exactly stain on the right typically
done
with poloidin and then the lower panel
shows another growth completed with 5
micromolar oxygen ox inhibitor vas 2870
for 70 minutes
so a significant reduction is effecting
content
and when we look at uric growth this is
on the next slide and here
is quantified total direct length per
cell in three different
conditions medium control
dmso vehicle control and then
the nox inhibitor bus in this case
two micro molar concentration
treated for a day so on day zero before
drug addition
the total neurite lengths per cell in
these three groups are
the same very similar but then
one day in drag you can see from the
black bar that the new red length is
significantly reduced compared to two
control
conditions then we wash out the drug in
this case
the cells are treated for a full day
with this dose
there is no reversible effect here and
the new rest
has stayed short while the control group
still continues to grow
so knox inhibition reduces neural
so depending on the species for example
in humans we have
seven members of the family of nox
enzymes and they are listed here we have
different numbers
they can be distinguished based on the
activation mode
and so what you see on this schematic
taken from a review by the darm krauser
you can see
in the upper left the knox one complex
then in the upper middle and the nox2 on
the upper right knock three
and the lower level on the left knox
four middle knocks five
and on the right two ox one and two so
all have these
enzymatic subunit that does the electron
transfer
from nadph onto molecular oxygen
producing
superoxide down here in red but they are
different in the way
they are regulated and activated
nox 1 2 and 3 are regulated by cytosolic
subunits
ox4 is constitutively active
and ox5 and the two duoxes are calcium
regulated
now we were curious to see whether any
of these are actually localized in
optical scans we are fortunate
to find antibodies that are actually
specific for some of these subunits
because these antibodies from mark quinn
and one two nodes two and one to the
cytosolic subunit
p40 here are the western blocks showing
that they're
pretty specific to absolutely your
proteins and then here in the middle
and on the right we see the
corresponding immunolabeling
so these are slightly permalinked cells
we see a punctual distribution
showing that these proteins are both
membrane associated and as you can see
in the case of nox2
also quite present
in the centerline on organelle membranes
now the next slide we have done a triple
stain
of these two subunits of knox 2
along with f acting so
in the upper panel you see each
individual stain
for the three different proteins and
then
on the lower panel first the triple
color overlay
and then zoomed in in that region of
interest
first the dual overlay of nox2 and p40
and you can see while labels are closed
there's not a whole lot of
yellow here there's not much
colloquialization
and this is likely because these growth
cones have not been stimulated
with any agent but under the same
condition same growth when you look at
p40 and that actin
you can see that many labels for
p40 are actually color classed with
effect
so that suggests that the cytosolic
supplement d4
actually is associated significantly
with the effects inside the skeleton
under non-stimulated condition
which has also been shown for other
cytosolic subunits in other cells
now the next slide shows what happens
when you stimulate the growth cone with
a particle that's coated with a
television protein
we call this the restrained bead
interaction assay to
induce growth con advance
in the upper left you see a dic image
you see that particle
at the right and it's holding place
with a micropipette you can see the dark
shadow of that
you can see how the central domain
actually moves towards that
bright particle it's a glass b
coated with a v10 then in the other
images you can see nox 2p40 and the
color overlay
what you can clearly see here is that
there is not only more
of those two proteins around the
adhesion site but they're also
co-localized
significantly at this adhesion site
suggesting that
the activation of lobster may play a
role in this process here
in adhesion in use advance and this is
quantified here
the right panel in for experiments
so the rbi area means the beat area the
adhesion area
where you have more colloquialization
than in adjacent areas
so moving on to the last part of the
talk
about the role of knox 2 now
specifically in
regulation of the development of retinal
textile connections in the zebrafish
this is worked by corey weaver hello
roser and austrian thirsty
so why zebrafish so
obligation is great for cell culture
studies as i mentioned because these
cells are big they're great for
quantifications of time lapse
fluorescence
and biophysical experiments however
there are significant
limitations in aphrodite as well there
is no knockout or transgenic lines
there's no individual imaging capability
they are difficult to breed and there
are invertebrates
on the other hand zebrafish they are
genetically tractable
they are great for level imaging they
develop
fast have many embryos it's a
well-established developmental model
system and they are working
so just as an example what you can do in
zebrafish this is an
example of imaging in the
living zebrafish brain of an embryo
using a specific line that expresses
fluorescent protein
gfp in retinal garment cells but only in
a few cells and this is called sparse
labeling the line description is given
here on the right
and what you actually see here is you're
looking at
the axonal terminals
in panel a are coupled and then in panel
b
in more detail at high resolution at
different time points
10 minutes intervals the growth comes in
the file of proteodynamics
of the retinal garment cell acts on the
growth comes
in the optic tectum indicated here on
the left side in the schematic
that's where the original ganglion cells
innervate the brain
so it's a very uh powerful mobile system
and technique we actually did this year
with livestream microscopy
which allows you to do high resolution
imaging for extended time periods
without
harming the sample
now we started the studies by treating
these zebrafish embryos with
an ox inhibitor in this case cholesterol
for a four hour time window indicated
here in the upper
left 2.5 micromolar and washing out the
drug
and then fix and stain or looking in
our live fish in specific lines that
express fluorescent proteins
and results are shown here first the
control
without the drug in the upper image you
see
looking at the eyes you know throttle
view
the two eyes and this is a line that
expresses tfp
in retinal ganglion shells under the
a105 promoter
this is at 48 hours post fertilization
so this is normal
you can see the arctic chiasm labeled
there
and the lower image shows one day later
the innervation of the optic tectum by
these
axons detectors are labeled on both
sides of the brain
now if these fish were treated with the
knox inhibitor cholesterol as
indicated in the upper left for four
hours
then we see some major changes the
gangnam style layer is widened
indicated by that bracket you don't see
the optic path that well it's still
there it's
enhanced in the inset and also
the areas of the optic tectum that are
innervated are small
and some of these effects can actually
be rescued by
treatment of hydrogen peroxide such as
the thickness of the optic nerve and the
area of innervation in the tectum but
not the thickness of the ganglion cell
layer and this is quantified down here
on the left side is the width of
the cell layers in control
and then celestrol is wider it cannot be
rescued by hydrogen peroxide
the middle graph shows the thickness of
the optic nerve and control
reduced by celestrol but rescued by
hydrogen peroxide by
adding back hydrogen peroxide and the
right panel
shows the area of tactile innervation
reduced by an ox inhibition but again
partially rescued by
adding back hydrogen peroxide
so drug experiments are great but we
also wanted to do
a more specific molecular manipulation
by creating mutants using
the crispr cast 9 technique so we
created
knox 2 homozygous mutant
and then looked at the retinogamine
cells the eye and again at the optic
textual innervation
so this is wild type we see
here the individual channels the
retinal garments are labeled sinate
nucleus stain and the overlay
we targeted these sky darnays to two
sides we call them guide on a one and
two
one targets very close to the n-terminus
two a little bit further in
but both will create non-functional
knocks with both sky rnas when we look
at homozygous
mutant these significant changes in the
retina
the very similar to what we observed
with the inhibitor so the gcl
is widened and this is also quantified
here
at two time points 48 and 72 hours
so with both mutations with both
approaches we see a widening of the gcl
and then we look in the brain in the
optic tectum
again first control so this is wild type
without the mutation we see
the typical innervation in green here of
the optic tectum
but then with both guidelines
with both types of not knocking out
nox2 we see severe perturbation of the
innovation so
it's diffuse innervated and it's not
compact
to the normal normally developed
architecture
and this is quantified by line skins
here on the lower right
for both guide armies so the bile type
would be the black line
and the two guide rna so the knox 2
knockouts
are shown by the red and green
so we also did some rs imaging
with genetically encoded file sentences
such as a roti of p2 or quant
indicated here and
first we did some validation so on the
left side lower panel
we are looking at the head of the
zebrafish embryo
the two eyes are indicated when you
treat them with hydrogen peroxide you
get more signals when we treat them with
reducing agent dtt the signals go back
indicated here by a warm colors
then we also looked at
cultured original garment cells and
using the same fire sensor so the left
side you see the ic images
at 10.0 and treatment with the guidance
cue sleep 2
after 30 minutes which actually causes
a stalling of the growth cone and sleep
2 treatment not only holds the growth
conic also increases
gross carbon hydrogen peroxide levels as
indicated here in the graph
in a double prime so rs levels are
increased
however in the mutants nox2 mutants this
doesn't occur
so slit 2 increases hydrogen peroxide
levels in an ox 2 dependent manner
and c2 also halves the growth
furthermore if you do a guidance assay
very applies a two
in a gradient fashion in an angle
indicated here by the arrow
these are enlarged images of growth
comes from culture
severe fish written down ourselves
so on the left tank on zero on the right
60 minutes later you can see
slipped two in the upper panel you see
the chromosome turns
to the left while in the lower panel
we add celestrol and optimizer
together with the sleek two gradient and
then the repulsive effect of sleep two
is abolished so the growth come kind of
enormously
as you see on the lower right this is
quantified again on the right
you can see that the normal effect of
sleep two which
is causing a negative angle is
abolished by the presence of nox to
individual
so the last set of data is shown here
this is in vivo data again
uh showing a retrogame cell axon
staining
in the arctic tectum as well as
statistics in wild type
nox2 heterozygous and also a double
heterozygote for nox2
and the c2 receptors robo2 which is
called
asteroid so that's the double
heterozygous
so when you quantify the area of
innervation you actually find
that nox two heterozygous fish
and as shown here on the right don't
have significantly reduced area of
innervation
as well as the asteroid heterozygospase
and that's the the green triangles but
in combination
the double heterocycle not too fast
drive
has actually reduced innervation this
suggests that these two
proteins nox2 and robot2 may be the same
pathway
so this is the pathway we think about
slip two the guidance cube binds to
receptor rule the cube
starting a signaling cascade that
ultimately
activates nox2 producing
superoxide hydrogen peroxide and then
ultimately affects downstream target
proteins such as cytoskeletal proteins
and signaling molecules such as sarc
which ultimately affects
axonal rules and guidance that's our
current
model i would like to summarize and
conclude
so first i showed you that lowering
growth on rs levels binoxin inhibition
reduces
effect on content but also effective
dynamics and uric growth
and i showed you that pharmacological
knobs inhibition in the zebrafish embryo
inhibits
the development of retinotectal
connections
and this can be confirmed with nox2
homozygous mutant and then we also
showed you
some in vitro data with culture neurons
that
nox inhibition abolishes the guidance
responses of
rtc axons to sleep too but we also found
that for other cues such as egnf
and neptune so in summary these findings
suggest
a role for nox to derive reactive oxygen
species
actual rules and guidance
last but not least i would like to thank
the people involved here so this is a
recent
picture of our lab i would like to
thank all my students and collaborators
listed down here on the left side in
this project
and of course also all the funding
sources from nhs
yana spinal cord the injury research
program
and also purdue thank you very much for
your attention
thank you
alrighty awesome job well we're all set
pretty much from here i'll just do some
quick editing on the front and
back end since there was no
interruptions during your presentation
and then i'll have it ready for the
event in a few weeks
thank you so it took a little bit longer
no no worries um still within the
time range so that's great and then if
any questions come up feel free to reach
out but if not
we will um talk to you soon
thank you so much for your help thank
you
have a good rest of your day and have a
good weekend
you too thank you thank you bye
bye